okay so we've seen that the cyclic
peptide tartare sitting b1 is not
produced based off of the genome so we
need to move beyond genome analysis to
try and figure out what its sequences
it's not going to be hidden in the
genome the tool that we're going to use
is the workhorse tool of this approach
and it's called a mass spectrometer
it's here's a photo of one that UCSD
uses and we're going to think of it as
an expensive molecular scale now this
asks an important question which is how
is it that we actually measure the mass
of a molecule so we're going to define a
Dalton as the mass of a proton or a
neutron approximately that's not an
exact measurement but it's approximately
what a Dalton is and the mass of a
molecule then is going to be equal to
the sum of the protons and neutrons and
all of the atoms of the molecule so
let's look at an example let's compute
the mass of glycine so glycine is an
amino acid and it has a chemical formula
C 2 H 3 o n all right so it has two
carbon atoms and carbon has 12 protons
and neutrons so we do 12 times 2 then we
have 3 hydrogen atoms each of mass 1 and
then we have a single oxygen atom of
mass 16 and a nitrogen atom of mass 14
so when we add these together we get an
approximate value of 57 Dalton's the
actual mass is 57 point zero 2 Dalton's
and that requires a more technical
precise definition of what a Dalton is
but we're going to use this rounded off
approximation to an integer and we're
going to refer to this as the integer
mass of glycine so we can compute the
integer mass of each amino acid that we
have and this gives us what we call the
integer mass table all right so you'll
notice we have the 20 amino acid masses
beneath the 1 letter abbreviation of
each amino acid so the question then is
well what's the mass of something like
Tara sitting b1 we know the sequence of
tired sitting b1 so we just need to go
through and compute its mass as the sum
of each individual amino acid so V has
mass 99
kay has mass 128 L has mass 113 and so
on so we can go through we simply add
the Constituent masses and we get 13 22
so that's the integer mass of this tire
sitting be one peptide I'll note before
we continue that two amino acid pairs I
and L as well as K and Q have the same
mass so when we weigh the molecules
we're not actually going to be able to
distinguish between I and L or
distinguish between K and Q and so we're
gonna move essentially from an alphabet
of 20 amino acids to an alphabet of just
18 integer masses we'll work mainly with
integers now in this talk I'll show the
actual amino acids in terms of their
letters but if you're working with them
on a computer you probably want to just
assume i NL are the same and assume K
and Q are the same so let me show you
then how this mass spectrometer works so
you're going to take multiple copies a
sample of this peptide and you're gonna
plug them into the Machine and then the
Machine is going to chop them up into a
lot of different pieces it's gonna blast
them into fragments and then essentially
it's going to weigh these fragments so
this is an ideal scenario where it gave
us the mass of every possible sub
peptide or fragment of this and qil
peptide circular peptide and I'll
highlight the masses because it doesn't
tell us what the sub peptides are it
tells us what the masses are notice that
here two of the masses to 42 are
equivalent so we're going to call this
the theoretical spectrum the theoretical
spectrum of a cyclic peptide is chop it
up into all possible fragments weigh
those fragments and then add 0 which is
just an empty string and 484 which is
the mass of the entire peptide so if you
know the sequence of a peptide computing
its spectrum is just a trivial exercise
chop it up into all pieces use the
integer mass table and figure out what
what the mass of each fragment is that's
not bad what about reversing it what
about going from the spectrum to the
peptide that's really the computational
problem that we have the mass
spectrometer generates a spectrum an
experimental spectrum and
we wanted to determine a peptide that
came from it that's going to be a harder
problem and we call this the cyclic
peptide sequencing problem so to
reconstruct a cyclic peptide from its
theoretical spectrum